c'est demain que le salon de l'auto
fermera ses portes à paris un salon
particulièrement couru cette année
à propos du salon on a surtout parlé
jusqu'ici des voitures bien sûr mais il
n'est pas trop tard pour parler moto
puisque une partie des stands est
consacrée aux mécaniques à deux roues en
vedette américaine si l'on peut dire
la moto française françois corner on
parle en effet souvent du salon de
l'auto beaucoup moins de celui de la
moto
et pourtant il était aussi difficile
aujourd'hui porte de versailles
d'accéder à ces machines qu'aux nouveaux
modèles à quatre roues des constructeurs
française ou étrangers beaucoup de monde
autour des deux roues les gros cubes
comme on les appelle un salon certes
moins important que son grand frère mais
tout aussi riche en nouveautés on
remarque comme d'habitude à la
présentation des modèles la compétition
entre les constructeurs
mené tambour battant par les japonais
derrière eux italien allemand espagnol
anglais et français essaient de suivre
concurrence sévère sur le plan technique
et commerciale le développement
considérable de la moto depuis une
quinzaine d'années à stimuler la
concurrence
les machines sont de plus en plus grosse
de plus en plus rapide
de plus en plus belle de plus en plus
sophistiqués un mythe plus fascinants
encore que celui de la voiture
mais à l'air avec les moutons qui vient
sur le marché français les japonais
restent largement en tête des ventes
62000 de leurs machines ont été
immatriculées chez nous depuis le début
de l'année soit huit fois plus que la
totalité des autres constructeurs réunis
moutons avec moi tous les ans vincent
printemps
il essaye de me suis quand même sur la
note
voir
s'aperçoit que chaque année la moto
qu'on a eu 20
d'ailleurs pas espoir de la france pour
son décollage sur le marché cette belge
et récents un moteur d'automobiles de
grande série une nouveauté qui n'est
plus un prototype et qui devrait selon
les spécialistes faire son chemin
y a pas d'âge pour la moto il ya 32 ans
que je roule et je suis toujours aussi
passionné je suis particulièrement
heureux de voir une
une machine française une telle qualité
les performances sur la route
le marché de la moto n'est certainement
pas prêt de s'écrouler l'attirance des
jeunes pour le deux roues est
significative
il faut dire que les constructeurs leur
font les yeux doux même à la plus petite
échelle